Let's look at the solution to our multi-predictor quiz where we
have a program for which the two bit predictor works for many instructions.
PSHARE covers some additional instructions and
GSHARE covers the rest that PSHARE doesn't cover. But all of
them can correctly predict the same branches that the two-bit predictor can.
So, because the two-bit predictor covers the most branches, and
it's the cheapest predictor, what we want to do is use the two-bit predictor for
most of the branches. So the correct answer here is E, Hierarchical predictor,
that chooses between a two bit predictor and
a predictor that combines the PSHARE and GSHARE. So,
what this first part does is it basically makes most of the branches just go
to the two bit predictor so that the space in the more expansive predictor here.
Will be reserved for only the branches that actually need to go there,
because the 2 bit predictor is not predicting them correctly. Because PSHARE and
GSHARE have different strengths and neither of them is clearly superior
to the other, we are not going to combine them using a hierarchy co-predictor,
we are going to combine them using a tournament predictor.
That will choose between PSHARE and GSHARE. So,
the correct answer is that the overall predictor is a hierarchical predictor
that chooses between a two bit predictor and a tournament predictor
which itself chooses between PSHARE and GSHARE or the other way around.